we've done a lot of talking about
interstellar empires on this channel
from the foundation series by Isaac
Asimov to dune by Frank Herbert and as
much of science fiction depicts
realistically I think in Atlantic City
insisting of billions of humans it would
be near impossible for one government to
truly maintain rule over all humans
there would almost certainly be
dissenters those that reject the
hierarchy and wish to form their own way
in the Hyperion cantos by Dan Simmons
the ouster z' was the name given to the
genetically distinct group of humans
which existed outside of the control of
the hegemony of man and populated the
outer rims of human space
[Music]
the ouster is varied widely in culture
and physiology because they had adapted
to the environments of many different
worlds the ouster developed a number of
augmentations allowing them to become
more suitable for the environments in
which they lived
some appear mostly human except for
elongated an animal like limbs and some
have webbed fingers or coats of fur all
of these differences are genetically
superficial however all owl stirs are in
fact human and have the potential to
reproduce with other humans within the
galaxy the genetic adaptations were
necessary and self-inflicted they were
required in order for the ouster x' to
survive even in the vacuum of space
austere angels are a division of
Elster's who are fully adapted to the
vacuum they exist adjacent other
clusters of owl stirs in orbital forest
rings or other such microgravity
conditions angels can feed off sunlight
and possess the ability to communicate
via bio radio transmissions owl stirs
came to be before humanity's big mistake
which would render the planet earth
uninhabitable and the Hegira which
followed in the beginning days of space
colonization numerous ships were sent
out into the vacuum of space headed for
faraway star systems
these ships contained altered human
beings embedded with nanotechnology
which could allow them to adapt quickly
to extraterrestrial environments these
humans sent out into the cosmos in
cryogenic chambers would go on to form
the groups referred to as the ouster z'
because of the need to survive in space
a lot of the technological innovation
among the ouster z' was related to the
optimization of life in low gravity
environments for example many owl stirs
had implanted wings which could be
extended outward soldiers wore suits
which included mechanical tails serving
as extra limbs or weaponry Oster ships
also possessed these tentacle-like
appendages
capable of gripping enemy ships though
they were thought of by many in the
hegemony as backward barbarians the
ouster 'he's actually had created
incredible works of engineering
eventually the AO sirs would even help
with the engineering of the star tree
biosphere which would be home to
templars how stirs and even alien
species the star tree was technically a
Dyson Sphere the concept of the Dyson
Sphere was first described by Olaf
Stapledon in the book Star Maker but it
was popularized and named for Freeman
Dyson who wrote in his paper search for
artificial stellar sources of infrared
radiation published in 1960 that such a
mega structure would be an assessee
to a sufficiently advanced enough
civilization a Dyson Sphere
would be the only way that such a
civilization could hope to possess
enough power to supply its energy needs
a Dyson Sphere could harness the power
of a star by completely encompassing it
the star tree of the Hyperion cantos is
one of many versions of a Dyson Sphere
to show up in science fiction the ouster
homes swarm itself was constructed of
many asteroids kept inside of
containment field tubes water streams
connected several of these tubes
allowing the ouster to travel between
different habitats the owl stirs who had
sequestered themselves from the rest of
humanity during the Hegira understood
the damage that far casting caused to
the void which binds due to this they
were against the use of them for
transportation the ouster also only used
conventional methods of space travel
which means it took them much longer to
move from place to place
how stirs are also known to for
migration clusters swarms of ships which
travel through the stars together these
clusters of ships can number in the
thousands and contain many kinds of
vessels small ships which consisted of
only a single person and even
terraformed Ashe
home to tens of thousands of humans
throughout the hegemonies existence
tensions between them and the owl stirs
had continued to increase
unlike the hegemony who chose to
colonize and terraform worlds the augh
sirs had chosen to colonize space itself
harvesting the resources of comets and
asteroids several armed conflicts took
place among the hegemonies outback
worlds and these tensions would
eventually lead to a war between the
hegemony and the ouster 'he's the ouster
would however outlive the hegemony and
later even pacts continuing to evolve
and adapt to the ever-changing universe
in which they lived the console who had
spent time among the ouster z' said this
in book 1 of the Hyperion cantos I will
not try to describe the beauty of life
in a swarm their zero gravity globe
cities and comet farms and thrust
clusters their micro orbital forests and
migrating rivers and 10,000 colors and
textures of life at rendezvous week
suffice it to say that I believe the
ouster z' have done what web Humanity
has not in the past millennia evolved
while we live in our derivative cultures
pale reflections of old Earth life
the owl stirs have explored new
dimensions of aesthetics and ethics and
Biosciences and art and all the things
that must change and grow to reflect the
human soul I believe that it is
plausible to assume that if the ouster
x' continued to evolve that eventually
their DNA will diverge enough from
normal human genetics that they will no
longer truly be human but perhaps
several new species then again who is to
say that it would be they that were
inhuman and not the others who had
chosen to stagnate to forego evolution
for a familiarity or security perhaps it
is the ouster x' who are honoring the
natural progression of the human species
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire also follow me on
Twitter
check out the ideas of Ice and Fire
subreddit and if you really want to
support this channel click the patreon
link in the description